now she is the best-selling classical
artist
of the century in a voice known across
the world
now catherine jenkins is preparing to
spread some christmas cheer for charity
let's have a listen and a sing-along
[Music]
is
oh oh they just caught the chorus
catherine joins us now
good to see you this morning yeah
yeah i was just about i was just about
to join in do you fancy a duet single
sometime catherine
absolutely we could definitely do
karaoke
[Laughter]
yeah karaoke is probably my limit to be
fair it is really good to see you this
morning talk is about this
this show that you're spreading to
hospitals
uh well i created a film um that we made
at the royal albert hall which is called
the catherine jenkins christmas
spectacular and the sort of the message
of that was
really trying to bring some christmas
cheer to families out there
at the end of a tough year you know when
they were talking in the news
potentially about christmas concerts and
cow services not happening i thought
no we have we have to have this we have
to get christmas music out to people
so we made a few a feature film um full
of all of the music from traditional to
contemporary christmas songs and dance
and special guests
um and we've been working with an
amazing charity called
medi-cinema who um show the show films
in hospitals to patients outpatients
um and to nhs uh staff and so
it's lovely to think that they'll get to
see the film and hopefully it will bring
them a little bit of respite and comfort
and christmas cheer
i know it'll surprise you catherine but
i am an old cynic i've been in this job
for too long and so i see
but when i read things like this i
sometimes think oh is that really going
to cheer anybody up
since we've been playing your clips this
morning i've been
singing my head off in every commercial
break
it really does work doesn't it it brings
a smile to our faces to see this
uh you know christmas music is amazing
in that you know it brings this
it brings us joy peace
a sense of nostalgia wonderful memories
um it warms the heart and and um i
wanted this to be a sort of
you know a feel-good old-fashioned
family style
um film with you know special guests and
sort of all of those
uh those songs that are emotional and
and warm our hearts and i had such
amazing fun making this you know we had
only a few days to film this with the
royal alcohol
it's not a concept by any stretch it's a
it's a story it's almost like a night of
the museum but it's a
christmas eve at the royal alcohol and
in this fantasy world me and family live
there of course
and uh the albert hall comes to life on
christmas eve you know
with so many other things we've got you
know bill
nye vanessa red graves silver and
tenville
um we've got the royal uh royal air
force regiment ban we've even got the
sugar plunge fairy it's a massive
delight to my daughter
i have to say the clips we've been
showing you in that red dress
sweeping down the corridors um
it's just fabulous because it is it is
sort of so old-fashioned so traditional
that's it's like a
something from the silver screen
well actually i referenced quite a lot
of you know i grew up
um being a massive fan of people judy
garland and judy andrews
um looking through some of those amazing
hollywood specials
um and what was also incredible was the
royal albert hall gave
us such amazing access so we were able
to film
um you know not just on the stage but on
the roof and in the basements and the
boxes in the backstage and
i i've spent quite a lot of time in the
roll up a whole bunch i learned about
spaces that i didn't know existed there
and so it's really nice to be able to
share all of that with the viewer
yeah look when is medi-cinema showing
this
oh i believe it's showing it now i mean
it's in it's in normal cinemas
um across the uk uh this month
um and it's out on dvd and you can see
on digital platforms i wanted to make it
accessible to as many people as possible
in that if you don't feel like you can
venture out of your home then of course
you can see it in the normal way you'd
watch a film
but it's just really lovely to think
that this is also going into hospitals
um and you know really going to the
people who i think need it most
um and i really hope that brings them
some some festive fun
and christmas cheer it just is it just
is i just know it is
um catherine go on then do us a favor
i'm dreaming of i'm dreaming of a white
christmas just
like the ones i used to know
you've got a great voice you actually
have a great voice i
i let yeah okay let's talk
we'll definitely have to do something
happens in my life i've done a duet with
katherine jenkins
really good to see you this morning
thank you very much indeed